Define what is helping the little guy
what has happened the little guy mean to
you
well
so
the way we got there was you know these
small businesses were obviously being
bullied by the system overall by visa
and MasterCard they set the rates that
the small businesses pay and like twice
a year they raise the rates on the small
businesses and there's no competition
it's not like the business can be like
okay I'm gonna stop taking Visa I'm not
I'm going to stop taking MasterCard and
so the small businesses basically have
to take whatever these big huge
companies say that they have to take and
it's really wrong and you know in a
place like Idaho where I grew up you
know you see the impact of that on those
small businesses far away from that
boardroom in New York City where they
decided we can increase our share price
by charging these small businesses that
can't afford it a bunch of fees for
money that we don't need to run our
business that we're then going to use to
inflate our our stock with stock
BuyBacks so that we can pay executive
bonuses and so I was seeing that as a 17
year old and there was a coffee shop
named Moxie Java Caldwell in Caldwell
Idaho and there was a the owner Heather
Hempel she was explaining to me how she
was getting screwed over and she didn't
necessarily know all the backstory of
like how it all works behind that but
she was explaining to me she was getting
screwed over and she introduced me to
some of her friends that said the same
thing so it's like how do we fight
against this how do we hold these big
companies accountable but
the name of the game right now in
business and in big Tech and big
companies in Big Wall Street is captured
in uh the work of Peter Thiel the book
zero to one where he wrote competition
is for losers so what the new kind of
people that style themselves as
capitalists actually believe they don't
believe in competition they believe in
using their money and their Superior
positions of power to Stamp Out
competition
and the entire economy is starting to
line up with that philosophy and you see
it zero two one you thought that yeah it
was seen in the book that's not what I
took from the book when he said zero to
one
well he he's he that's an exact quote so
your reading skills maybe I know that
but I think what he was trying to say is
have you read Blue Ocean strategy
yeah yeah I think that's the direction
where he was going like create a market
where there is no competition like you
know where you're where you're going
into a place where you're the you know
first one to go out there and do it you
don't have anybody else to compete
against versus Go destroy everybody and
dominate the entire Market well well
that's what Theo was talking about let's
look at the weight of the evidence to
see if what you're you're positive is
correct or mine so he made two other big
points the two biggest points in the
book actually that contextualize the
statement
number one if you really want to be
significant if you really want to matter
you need to be a billionaire
that was his first point in the book and
that's very much in line with zero to
one it's binary it means by that do you
know what he means let me let me finish
and then and then I'll sh and then I'll
see what yeah I do know what he means I
think I do tell me
yeah yeah either you're a zero
which means a non-billionaire
you don't matter
or you're a one
which means you're a billionaire you do
matter
that's the ideology that regular people
all over are seeing and it's one thing
for us to say well I want to keep that
intact because I want to get there I
want to climb that ladder but if you
look at the social Mobility statistics
that are out there right now having a
ladder like that isn't climbable and
here's why it's his second point so
that's his first thesis point but he has
two parallel Theses in that book how do
you become a billionaire how do you
become somebody that matters he asks
that question and he says
that the only way to become a
billionaire is to have a monopoly and
the reason why
is because if you have a monopoly you
can act with impunity there's no
accountability and he uses softer
language than that but if you think
about the implication you can lay off
employees with no consequences you can
go be like Uber Eats and you can get
cardi B and Dana Carvey to do some kind
of Wayne's World commercial and spend 10
million dollars at the same time that
your business model is trying to extract
maximum value from local businesses and
you do a commercial claiming that you're
helping local businesses at the same
time you're laying off employees at the
same time you're paying huge executive
bonuses and at the same time that you're
buying out competitors I mean this is
what people on Reddit that some people
would call her crazy think of as late
stage capitalism because it's like where
can you actually take things after this
like where do you go next and basically
since the 1970s or the 1980s
so much of our success in business has
been about squeezing people about
exploiting workers that's been the
that's been around the economy but now
it's becoming just more and more scammy
throughout and if you think about your
own life just when you go out and live
your life how many scams are you
subjected to on a daily weekly or
monthly basis now or how many times are
you kind of slightly mistreated and it
could be little things like getting the
text to lose 100 pounds with a diet pill
I'm looking at you you definitely should
not lose 100 pounds that would be a bad
thing it could be that the scam phone
call claiming to be Social Security
Administration it could be it could be
the fact that you know you used to check
into a hotel and whatever price they
told you the price was was the actual
price and now there's a 50 Resort fee or
you go into an airline and you can pay
the yeah the rate that they advertise
but to do it you're going to sit in the
middle seat by the bathroom and so so
much more of our economy now is designed
to extract maximum resources engineer
use those resources to marshal
to Marshall you know engineering
um capabilities and then engineering a
space away from competition or away from
actual even customers I mean we have
examples of businesses like ubereats
that will claim that they're advertising
for a local company and then be
redirecting that company's customers to
a different company and it's a complete
scam and it's legal and so going back to
Peter Thiel with his second point of how
do you become a billionaire he said the
only way to do it really is to become a
monopoly so that you can act with
impunity so what I'm sharing to you
about Heather
and other people like you that didn't
start out from much they're being held
down more than you realize by this
system that we're all supporting and
yeah it's true that we have individual
examples like yourself that show the way
and show wow somebody can be successful
but what those examples do and I'll
actually point the finger at myself more
than anybody else but what those
examples do is they kind of lie to us
they make us think that the system does
promote and allow people to get ahead
when actually the fact that that we get
held up you and I get held up on
pedestals proves the opposite it proves
that we are the exception and it proves
that most people don't reach that and
just for myself you know you pointed out
how 500 million people had seen my story
and how people were so enthusiastic
about it how low is the bar
when somebody who basically says the
people actually creating the value
should get it they should have autonomy
and we should work together to help
small businesses gets that kind of
attention how much does that prove how
low the bar is because everything that I
did you can't find a single thing I did
that a nice eight-year-old wouldn't do
and yet that was the response yeah so I
think it shows everything about where we
are right now no I think I think the
reason why that story went viral is
because the younger generation relates
to a ton and they're coming out of
college and they're more in the state of
rich people are bad people capitalism
sucks because that's what the University
is doing that's what they're teaching
them and then all of a sudden they see a
story like you and they're going to
share the hell out of it and I'm glad it
got the exposure because we need to have
this discussion
foreign